[Music]
hello
and welcome to trigonometry i'm francis
foster
i'm constantine kissing and this is the
show for you
if you want honest conversations with
fascinating people
our fantastic guest today is an
archaeologist historian former
journalist tv presenter and all sorts of
troublemaker
neil oliver welcome to trigonometry oh
thanks guys thanks very much for uh
making me welcome it's good to have you
here i hope that introduction does make
you welcome
uh for anyone who's not familiar with
with what you do and
kind of just give us a little overview
of your life story so far
how are you where you are sure i'm i'm
mostly i suppose
a tv presenter and author
uh i've spent the last 20 years making
television documentaries of various
sorts
famously series called coast which did
what it sounds like
we followed the coastline of britain and
other places uh
lots of history lots of archaeology my
background
is uh well i have a degree in
archaeology from glasgow university
about a thousand years ago
and i have dodged around ever since i
retrained for a while as a journalist i
worked in
weekly papers did some stuff on the
national press as well
but about 20 years ago i accidentally
got into television and i've been
trying my best to get away with that
ever since
and and here we are today fantastic
and so you've got a passion for it for
history neil and i think
uh what we are seeing right now is a
world going slowly tonto can you see
patterns
in history being repeated now absolutely
i'm
i'm an archaeologist but i love history
um
i call myself an amateur historian or an
enthusiast i just love the stories and
the storytelling of it
and part of what i love about it is how
accessible it is to anyone if you can
read
if you can if you can read a book you
can read history
and for as long as they last the
libraries and bookshops
are full of history and as long as you
read widely
and make a point of reading things that
you don't agree or
with or like as well as things that you
do like and agree with then you can then
you can give yourself a good background
in history without any outside help you
don't need to go to college or
university to get an understanding of
the past
and if you do persevere and you read
widely and you'll be back into as far
back as you can go and come forward
towards the present you see patterns
without a shadow of a doubt
and i think that's where a lot of the
reassurance comes the reassurance that i
find is available in history and
archaeology
you see that our ancestors have dealt
with all of it
before war famine disease
invasion religious intolerance climate
change
natural disaster anything and everything
that we are going through or still have
to go through
our ancestors went through and and
fundamental to why i find it reassuring
is that without a shadow of a doubt they
had to face it with
not a fraction of the technology and
the understanding and the acquired
wisdom that we have
on account of them having gone through
it before and so
so knowing that our ancestors have had
to deal with the same sorts of
challenges
we're in the middle of the covert 19
lockdown
world pandemic well pandemics have come
before
as has every other big challenge for
humankind
and i think what i'm aware of more than
anything else at the moment is
you mentioned of a world gone turn to
you know people sort of losing the plot
and i say well of course we are
it's so much to ask people to cope with
and and is it any surprise that all
sorts of inter
and inter-community strife
has been a collateral damage of all that
we've expected ourselves and each other
to go through for the last
months on end and for me other people
would find a different
antidote to all the trouble but for me
i keep reading my history books and i
keep thinking
you know yes this has happened before
and this too shall pass
well it's a reassuring message that this
too shall pass and you talk about the
fact that humanity has faced these sort
of challenges before
and actually it's a thing that francis
and i frequently argue about because
he feels like a lot of the events of the
recent months
uh are largely the product of the of the
pandemic and people being locked up and
so on
in their homes i but i also feel that
there's another part to it which is
a longer-term civilizational
transformation where
the united states the west more
generally has gone from a kind of
confident
bold civilization that sought to be
powerful in the world so to expand so to
control as much as possible
uh whereas now it's turned inward and it
looks into
itself and i would say there's probably
some historical precedent for that as
well how do you
see the interplay between those two
things yeah
i mean amongst others uh an english a
british historian kenneth clark
livery an art historian art critic he
wrote
a book called civilization number of
years ago and then it became a you know
an
iconic television series uh and part of
his assertion within that thesis was
that um
that civilizations get exhausted
and he pointed to for example rome and
the roman empire and yes it was it was
coming under pressure
by the end from all sorts of external
challenges the barbarians at the gates
and all the rest of it
but he said that that was really um a
symptom of something
internal that the roman empire had just
lasted for so long
that it had become it lost confidence in
itself
and he said that's how civilizations
finally are undone
not because the barbarians get through
the gates before that
it's this loss of sense of self and i
think yes
it's so that has happened before and and
there are more examples than just all of
the empires
that we've ever always gone extinct if
you like
by definition there's been a sequence of
empires and kingdoms through history
and they've all gone uh and now you know
for a long time it has been this western
civilization that has been
uh predominant on the planet but perhaps
with lost confidence and we've also had
since i suppose really since the end of
the second world war
perhaps we've lived so many people in
much of the west have lived in
increasingly peaceful
tolerant times and we've begun to take
for granted
uh prosperity and peace and tolerance
and
and uh you know the chance of a good
life our children are taken care of and
we're well educated and all the rest of
it
and you can come to think of that as
being in the natural order of things
as though you know you can just uh leave
people to the to the natural
inclinations and devices and you'll get
this kind of civilization
and i think it's because we've had so
long without facing big
scary real challenge you know we haven't
had to endure our children
or ourselves going off to war you know
when facing the bayonet or the bullet
and we haven't been challenged by you
know an epidemic or a disease
and i think we've we've uh we've we've
lost
touch with some of the realities of life
and i think at the moment i think this
this pandemic and then the ever-present
threat that's been there for
for years now of climate change and all
sorts of predictions of the end of the
world i think people are rattled
and to some extent this this pandemic
has been one of if not the last
straw that has finally destabilized
people and we need to
you know it's not the end of the world
but i think we need to pull back
and take some sort of collective breath
and and appreciate that we need to give
each other and
ourselves more slack because we can cope
with this challenge
but we have to accept that there may be
some pain
there will be some pain there will be
there will be dying there will be there
will be blood and strife
but that's in the natural order of
things
every generation or so many generations
before ours had to face these realities
that people
some people die and and some people are
overwhelmed by circumstances but
civilization can persevere
and and we get that encouragement that
reassurance that all of that is possible
by looking at the past
and seeing the ancestors with far more
limited
uh equipment on our own found a way
through
and sought to overcome and did so
and neil do you think part of the
problem is is that we've got access to
history we've got this great wealth of
knowledge
but the reality is we're simply not
learning the lessons from the past
yes i think we're uh i i know for a fact
that you know but i've got kids at
school uh and history is not
uh one of those subjects that's at the
forefront
it's it's very much a kind of a luxury
option
and even though i'm you know i've forced
our kids
out from one castle to another and from
one battlefield to another over the
years
has opted to take history you know
they've all gone
in different directions but it's not a
it's not a a subject that's to the fore
and i do very much lament that
uh and i also i as well as
considering what people rightly describe
as history which is to say the written
word you know we've had the written word
for about five thousand years let's say
uh and so we've had documents and
letters and diaries and
all the stuff of history but i look back
even further you know i look back into
the evidence that's revealed by
by archaeologists you know going back
thousands
or hundreds of or even millions of years
into the past
because i think there are fundamental uh
understandings that we need to be
reminded of
about the nature of our species you know
homo sapiens
the wise people which we you know vainly
call ourselves we're only about two
hundred thousand years old
were relatively recent arrivals on the
planet
and there's a there's a an american
biologist scientist called edward
osborne wilson usually cited as e.o
wilson and there's a great quote from
them which is that
humanity's prediction predicament is
that we have
paleolithic emotions medieval
institutions
but god-like technology and those
all of those three statements are
absolutely correct
and it's so important to remember that
we are essentially the same animals
cognitively and physiologically
as the ancestors who hunted mammoths and
rhinos
and we lived as hunters for 90 of our
time on earth
and only 10 000 years ago did we did
some of us become farmers start
domesticating
plants and animals and after 10 000
years believe it or not we're still
psychologically coming to terms with
that change after 10 000 years
you know we still talk about the daily
grind which is to say the repetitive
chores without end well that comes from
literally grinding wheat into flour
rising it dawn
work until sundown knowing that tomorrow
is going to be exactly the same
and that your diet is going to be this
repetitive bread and porridge with the
occasional meat
you know uh you know humdrum existence
we're still coming to terms with that
and in the last few hundred years we've
had
uh you know you know enlightenment
and the coming of reason industrial
revolution uh
and in the last few decades even just in
the last few years the technological
advances
that we've had to try and cope with even
the smartest of us
struggle to cope with what's going on
and i certainly don't i don't put myself
even in the in the top half i you know
and i am i know i am struggling and even
the
the sharpest of the sharp the most
cognitively enabled to deal with modern
technology
are finding some of a struggle and it's
important to look back and remember that
we are
our brains are still processing about
four bits a second
now compared to the technology that
we've surrounded ourselves with
we're incredibly we're incredibly slow
you know our machines that we have
created are digital but we are still
analog for the time being and we have to
allow
uh for our own uh we have to remind
ourselves of our own potential and of
our own reality
we and we get that not just from
studying history but but from looking
back into the deepest
time we can reach and and it's
interesting that you mentioned i knew
because one of the things that i would
say
troubles me a lot about what's happening
in modern society
is the sense that i remember you know
growing up as a student
i read so many books about uh human
psychology
evolutionary psychology how our past
shapes our present
and our behavior and so on and it seems
to me like some of the movements that
we've seen coming
in in the last 10 15 years they almost
reject
the idea that anything from the past can
teach us anything about
the present anything about ourselves and
so on uh is that something that you
notice as well or am i imagining that
no i think that's i think that's right i
think
you know to continue my my previous
thought you know
we've asked a lot of ourselves and in
the last maybe 500 years at the very
most
although in reality less than that some
of us some tiny percentage of us
have trained themselves to be scientists
to think as scientists
and it's very very difficult even for
trained scientists to think like that
to to use brains in that way and even
trained scientists can only really do it
for short
spans of time it's like 100 meter
runners that they just have this burst
of
of activity that they've trained for the
rest of the time they just think like
the rest of us do
and our hunt ourselves you know we're
running this hunter software from the
past
and we have a constant i think desire to
not be scientists and to and to and we
have a void within ourselves that needs
to be filled by something else it's like
belief
uh its stories and its myth you know
which which served
for thousands of years to do the job of
science
we understood our place in the cosmos
and the nature of reality through
stories and myth and belief
and you can it's almost as if it's like
a
it's like a uh you know something that's
still pulling us down
but below the surface that that's
science now
uh is being i think undermined by our
our natural tendency to want to believe
in something
and i noticed the way in which you know
in relation to say the pandemic there's
this
talk about the science as though science
has become fixed as though it has become
something that is solid and permanent
like a like a stone with with permanent
words graven in it
and as a non-scientist i understand
science to be the opposite of that
science is never finished never come
never complete and there's never
scientific consensus i mean there should
always be doubting voices but
i think there's increasingly in these
troubled times there's been a desire to
to treat science as another kind of
religion
just believe it not to challenge it
uh you know the biology some aspects of
biology that i certainly took for
granted having done higher biology at
school
are some of those things that i took for
granted as scientific
fact are being are being dismissed now
uh as as not science uh and i think
uh that that was a the first step but
then
this uh tradition of not this tradition
but this idea of
woke has become this that has become a
set of
uh dogmatic statements that people
have to believe and not challenge
and you know we were supposed to have
got beyond all of that
this the world of reason the world of
science was supposed to have replaced
the world of belief in the world of
dogma but it turns out that it hasn't
and it doesn't
and that given enough time plenty of us
are now trying to treat science and
other ideas
as a dogma that must be revered
in the same way that a religion is that
there are certain
unviable truths that you certainly have
to accept
that there are sacred texts that must
never be challenged
and that there are sinners and heretics
that you know that must be punished and
driven out
and so i think it's a reminder and
and the explanation for we might be
doing for why we might be doing that
is because we are we struggle at all
times
to apply reason and science and if we if
we take our eye off the ball we start to
drift back towards
belief and dogma and we should be aware
of that
and the warning of that is there in in
history
neil and uh you're talking about you
know heretics and
you know casting them out and as a good
catholic boy i approve of all of that
that's why i was raised that's what i
was taught to believe
but joking aside don't you think a lot
of our problems come from the fact
that in the west we no longer think that
we need religion we don't believe in it
and anymore
by and large and we think that we're
above it but the reality is
isn't there something within us that
needs that kind of
belief system i think yes i think as it
turns out we are hardwired
i think there's i think there's some
part of um read-only memory
you know in our motherboards that we
can't get at and can't
un-program or reprogram that in spite of
everything else
is still hungry for you something like
belief
you know and and there's a tendency
towards having wanting to have
faith in something um
and religions you know evolved to fill
that void for the longest time
and people in the 21st century the 20th
century are wary about the supernatural
aspect of believing in a you know an
invisible
omniscient deity you know for all sorts
of perfectly valid reasons
you know that they harbor these doubts
but that's to that's to throw out the
baby with the bathwater i think
you know you know the judeo-christian
tradition
apart from expecting belief in an
invisible deity it also gave people a
framework by which to live their lives
and i don't think there's any arguing
with the fact that the value system that
evolved as these religions
served better than what we've been being
offered in the much more recent past
you know we got beyond religion as it
were in the west in this
19th century and other
as people have said before you know when
when you take about religion people
don't believe in nothing they believe in
anything
and ideologies emerged in the 19th and
20th centuries
that were supposed to give a superior
set of values by which to live
but what did those sets of values
actually do well they harvested hundreds
of millions of people
you know even the worst of the crusaders
in the palm couldn't even have dreamt of
notching up death tolls like that like
those which were achieved in the
in the 20th century and so we've got to
be mindful of the fact that we need we
need values by which to live
and it's useful we shouldn't be
embarrassed or
bashful about looking back and
acknowledging that the old lessons
learned even thousands of years ago are
still
valid you know things like don't kill
don't judge lest you be
judged be kind to your neighbors and
treat them as you would yourself
you know look after your mum and dad
these are these are
realizations that people came to
thousands of years ago
and every bit and every bit is valid and
we shouldn't get we shouldn't be
wary reminding ourselves of those
essential values well speaking of
reminding ourselves of values neil one
of the things that
uh wasn't on your list but i know you i
imagine you feel strongly about it
as i do is that whatever
replacement we seem to have been offered
for the religions of the past
the one thing that almost every major
religion has had in the past is the idea
of redemption and forgiveness
and that seems to be the one thing that
some of these new ways of thinking don't
seem to include and you you alluded to
it by saying
judge not least you be judged but i
think we've gone way beyond that
you know in terms of encouraging
judgment encouraging
mobbing of people encouraging punishment
for heretics as you say
i think i think something that you you
know whether whether or not
a person believes in a you know a deity
or some invisible force
there's no doubting that there was a
value in
in accepting that there were certain
powers that ought
to be human that should that should be
transcendent
you know um uh the idea that
there are certain godlike you know to go
back to eo wilson's quote
godlike powers belong somewhere else and
we shouldn't take them for ourselves
and maybe at the moment we're in one of
those dangerous areas that have happened
before where
we as human beings have are almost
indulging ourselves with the right to
have
you know godlike powers of destruction
of
fellow human beings and for a long long
ago
a lot of people realized that that
wasn't a good idea
that the operating in that way is
ultimately going to burn
us all but the the this culture around
woke a cancer culture it is
we are behaving in like old time
religion
and and the the the total destruction
that is being sought
in the case of the new heretics
is is a red light warning you know back
in the
you know back in the 16th century in
england when henry viii
famously broke away from the catholic
church and established what became the
church of england
um it unleashed obviously you know
centuries of strife
between catholic and protestant and then
when his when his daughter
mary became queen mary the first
uh she was she returned to the catholic
or she was catholic
and she famously sought to be burning
alive the burning at the stake of
more than 300 uh protestant heretics
and that was a deliberate choice of
punishment because the idea was that by
burning the body
nothing of it would remain there
wouldn't be so much as a finger bone
that could become be revered as a as a
relic
of a martyr and so it was burned to
ashes and then ashes
were scooped up and dumped in the river
so there was nothing
nothing left behind that was a very
specific punishment
it was carefully thought out almost
scientifically
and what's happening at the moment uh is
although
although the zealots of cancer culture
haven't actually burned anyone alive yet
and not yet the nature of the punishment
is such that the person be utterly
destroyed
in everything but the corporal sense you
know so
loss of career loss of livelihood loss
of good name
reputation built up over decades
hopefully they would say loss of family
you know love of family love of
relationship
so that nothing is left of the heretic
an empty husk
but don't you think neil didn't part
sorry to interrupt but don't you think
neil this goes
back to human nature in that we have a
light side to us
and there is a darkness to us and this
cancer culture this wishing to destroy
people because they have the wrong
opinions
is something deeply ingrained within us
within our dna as it were
and you can see it right the way through
history the stocks and all the rest of
it
and the reality is we're never going to
get away from it are we well
it's certainly we can't we can't really
confidently point back to time when it
wasn't there
you know you know is
arguably some people say it could have
its roots in the second millennium bc
yeah you know so it's but in any event
it's a lot older than
than christianity um and it was fun
it's duelist it was fundamentally about
the the reality was split between good
and evil light and dark
so right back in the roots of what
became religion was this idea of
you know good and evil light and dark
and we see
all you know in the in the symbol of yin
and yang that the idea of the
the black and the white tadpole curled
together you know light and dark
you know the two opposing forces but
coiled together in each with a
the white has black within it and the
black is white within it
and there's a there's a way between the
two that you're supposed to straddle so
we've had this understanding and then
as recently and as fundamentally
important
um alexander soldier nickson in the
gulag archipelago
you know wrote about how the the line
separating good and evil
passes not between states or political
parties or nations
it passes through the center of every
human heart
and if i could have everyone given that
permanent
reminder of the reality of human nature
it's that
it's that each one of us has to accept
that we have within us the concentration
camp guard the torturer the murderer
that's us you know the monster isn't
other people
it's it's within us each one of us has
the potential
and furthermore i think as you know you
see you when you see people that are
happily leaping onto cancel culture
and joining in the the mob attacks
and it's very often it seems to be
people that have previously
regarded and publicized themselves as
being loving and kind
and yet they can be some of the most
aggressive in the pylons that happen
with this kind of cancer
uh culture and it's what it's in that
behavior that you get an early warning
of the kind of people who would be
who would be the ones who would phone
the the secret police about their
neighbors
and watch but from behind the net
cuttings as their doors were kicked in
or be the orbee the guards and the
gulags
you that's that's the early warning of
the people who would behave
uh in that way and if you don't if you
don't accept that
each one of us has the potential to be
like that then you're an exceptionally
dangerous creature
you know but as long as you do realize
that the monster
is in you then you that's why
you accept ideas like judge not lest you
be judged
because you have to think well i could
be extremely
inhumane and judgmental if i was let
loose with absolute power
you know it's not like from like the
little caligula movie you know if you
had life and death power over every man
woman and child what would you have done
i make the world a better place might
[Laughter]
have to remind yourself if you were in
charge i would burn myself a mistake i'm
going to be honest with you
um but that's that is the that is the
point and we
it's it's it's you can take a light view
or a dark view of this realization
for me uh accepting that uh
that we're we are each of us you know 50
50
good and evil that we have them that we
have the monster within us
i take that on board and accept and i i
find comfort in it
and it's an extension of the fact that i
find comfort in the fact that we are
still
the paleolithic hunters that we have
been for
200 250 000 years
some people contemplating that might
find it discouraging
but i find a comfort in it that we are
just what we have always been
and in a sense all that's required is
that we accept
kind of internalize the reality of
ourselves
and that's where you find the the
induced
the you know the encouragement to not
judge
because you know if you know what you
are like then you know what everybody
else is like
if you know the things that would hurt
you then you know how to hurt everybody
else
and that's as long as you've
internalized that that aspect of human
nature then you become much less of a
threat
but but don't you think neil that the
problem is when it comes to things like
social media is that it dehumanizes
people so they're not a person anymore
they're an avatar they're just a little
picture so when you actually destroy
them it doesn't it takes away the human
element of them
because you don't then see what the
person is going through emotionally and
all the rest of it
oh yeah yes without without a shadow of
a doubt
i think we're a long way from from
understanding
psychologically what we've done to
ourselves with with social media
and the rest of it you know if you know
thousands of years ago if you were a
farmer
and you had a farmer over the stone wall
from you to
you know tending his fields uh if he was
doing something better than you
you know it'd been a better way to grind
tweet into flower or whatever
you might be you know unsettled by that
but because he was in your world and he
was really then you could see him
you could seek to emulate whatever it
was that he had done you know you could
you could copy
what he was doing uh elevate yourself
and then and then the feeling of
inadequacy and and being threatened by
him would go away
but because we've got these screens now
in our pockets and on our desks
let us see lives thousands of uh miles
away perhaps
lives that by definition because they're
on screen we can't even be confident
that they're actually real
you know we could actually be being
tricked by a fiction
but nonetheless we're unsettled by those
distant lives
in different climates in different parts
of the world lived by people in
different circumstances
and so we can't do the same thing we
can't seek to
meaningfully emulate or copy them it's
not realistic
and so all you're left with is this uh
triggered
unsettled threatened feeling that you
get well and we also watch
you know uh threat dangerous events
unsettling events thousands of miles
away and we still feel the threat
as though it was happening right there
in the room with us you know we're still
being we're being triggered by by the
fear of things that are
that are at a great distance and so
we're in these we are like you see we're
in these hamster balls we're in these
these little plastic balls that keep us
at a distance
from one another and then when we and
then when we watch people being torn
limb from limb
metaphorically speaking by the by the
twitter mob or whatever
we don't see we don't seem to see it as
happening to a real person it just seems
to be the consequences that
unfold for as you see on avatar in a
video game
because it does feel that way let me ask
you something else because
you know you all know harare writes very
well about
yes how it is that you homo sapiens
became the dominant species of humans
eventually becoming the only species of
humans that are left and what he talks
about is
we were able to overcome the fact that
physically we're quite puny compared to
say neanderthals or obviously you know
while other types of wild animals
um but but we overcame it by being able
to organize beyond our small tribal
groups and the way we did that is by
having
some sort of overarching idea uh the
nation
religion god whatever it might have been
and we were able to unite into large
groups
large tribes and it seems to me that
what's happening now is
a lot of the things that used to be a
unifying force we talked about religion
already but perhaps
the idea of the nation state all of
these things seem to be
either being eroded or entirely under
attack
what what do we have that we can unite
around
to to come together as we need to
you're right i mean harari writes you
know brilliantly and
and so illuminatingly uh about this idea
that um
you know say for example manchester
doesn't uh exist in any absolute sense
it's a it's a shared dream or a concept
it's a set of buildings and streets and
all the rest of it for the people of
manchester i'd like to say neil's not
attacking manchester
talking about any city
but the united kingdom yeah doesn't
exist in any absolute sense
and neither does a city so you know for
the sake of it you know let's say you
know
manchester is a shared idea to the
extent that if you were to if you were
to flatten it
to rubble and then take away all the
rubble and let the grass grow
manchester would still exist in the
minds of the people and so
the people could it would it could be
rebuilt and it would still be manchester
and it would never have been
it would never actually have disappeared
at any moment even when the grass had
grown over the site manchester would
still have existed so harari writes in
this brilliant way about how you can
unite people we have the cognitive
abilities
to share an idea and when it when it
becomes something like a religion
it's it's great because it means that
you can even though you've never met
someone
else if you know that they share your
religious beliefs you can predict how
they're going to behave in a given set
of circumstances because
you've been sort of trained and briefed
in in how to
behave in exactly the same way in
exactly the same set of circumstances
and so in answer to your question uh
if it's no longer going to be belief in
a
you know an invisible deity or a sacred
rock or a mountain
or whatever i think we have to have uh
we have to have the ability uh to have
shared dreams
shared aspirations you know that the
united
united kingdom obviously at the moment
is in a kind of a
is a is an in an uncertain state because
there's a big
pool from from scotland you know to
break the
to break that union between scotland and
and england and so
you know so that the existential nature
of the united kingdom is
is under threat at the moment but
it's that would be transcended as long
as it would not be a threat as long as
enough people continue to believe
in the existence of the united kingdom
you know you can't you can't do away
with it i think
i think in answer to your question we
have to we have to you we have to unite
around
a shared ideal and and a shared
aspiration and and the kind of quite
frankly the kind of civilization that we
have had
in our part of the west for quite a long
time now is the best aspiration i think
that
the human species has had so far
it's imperfect of course it is and
there's room for improvement but
the potential for a good life that has
been available
in this part of of the west and in north
america
is is the is the best idea that anyone
has ever had
i mean even the you know the idea of the
united states of america i often think
is the best idea ever written down
about what a civilization ought to be
you know and to summarize it as
life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness
who ever had a better idea than that as
the foundation
of a society and and the point is it has
never been realized it has never
happened yet but that's not a bad thing
i sometimes think you know donald
trump's idea about and make america
great again
would have been better if he had just
stopped at make america great
because you know to say make america
great again is to
stick a finger in the eye to people and
to say you know we were great before
we're going to do it again
it's better to to have it as an
aspiration
and likewise to think that the ideas
that underpin the united kingdom of
great britain you see things that are in
magna carta and in other documents
they remain they aren't really
aspirational you know
you might say that great britain has
never happened yet
in the same way that the idea that make
america great
is a is really the aspiration you know
your man's reach must always exceed his
grasp
and i think if we just have the
confidence to
to remind ourselves that what has been
sought
in the west is the best idea for a
civilization anyone's ever had
and it's an unfinished work we never got
there this
this idea that greatness is in the past
that's
that's that's fatal you know as though
it's gone as though it's behind us
i think in answer to your question it's
the idea that people come together
in their thousands and in their millions
in the shared belief
that greatness is possible but just
not quite reached yet and neil do you
think
one of the major problems our society is
facing is this sort of
advent of hyperliberalism which says
that we are all individuals which
you know once you put on the layer of
identity politics we're all different
from one another
we all have different privilege we all
have different right whatever it may be
and that is increasingly encouraging us
to see us ourselves
as individuals therefore not a
collective and is therefore fragmenting
society
that's difficult because i hear what
you're saying and i'm thinking about it
but the great you know part of the
success in the west has been
the the respect for and almost the
sanctity of the individual
you know the idea that you know it's
there in the uh in the
in the national covenant of scotland you
know which which was a contract
self-consciously written out by lawyers
in the
in the 17th century which in which
scottish people were invited to sign a
contract with god
and the kind of central tenet of it was
that every
every soul counted the same in the eyes
of god whether you were the king
or a ploughman or a fish wife or
whatever if we so weighed the same
uh and that that element of the unique
value of every individual
has been has been a central plank of
what has been achieved in the west i
think
but yes when you say that i can see that
maybe perhaps some of the ideas being
corrupted a bit in an unhelpful way
and it has been and it has morphed
unhappily into
you know identity politics and
intersectionality and all
and all the rest of it but i would still
i would still maintain that
it's almost like you know the statue of
justice outside blindfold on
i think that idea of being judged
blindly is a good one
the idea that you're not the justice or
the judge isn't looking at you and
seeing you as
black white male or female gay or
straight
whatever nationality you know it's just
that you make your declaration the
evidence is stated and
and that judgment comes down based on
those facts but i think i would still
ultimately i think there has to be some
uh some
respect for uh the
the the importance of seeing each one of
us as an individual
i think if we can do that i think if we
if we are able to see each other just
almost with our eyes closed just accept
each individual presence
as being of equal value i think that i
do think that is a
fundamental plank of a civilized society
and actually quite a revolutionary idea
for for for human history and i i do
think it's important i guess what
francis is
is getting that is where do you draw the
line between
going too far down the route of
individuals and particularly when
you have some of these kind of very
divisive narratives as we do now
which seek to not just tell you that you
as an individual are valuable and you're
you have significance but that you as an
individual are uniquely different from
everybody else there's nothing that
binds you in common with others i think
that's really
where some of the problems are coming
from yes i think
i um uh you know in in
researching for a television uh series
and a book that i did a few years ago
about the history of scotland
i ran across a a character
francis hutchison who had the chair of
moral philosophy
at glasgow university
in the you know the 1730s onwards for a
number of years
and he he quite quite controversially at
the time
taught that happiness was something to
be worked for
you know there was a sort of a
prevailing belief around at the time
that your happiness was almost like
manna from heaven
that god scattered almost at random and
you either got it or you didn't
it was god's will but francis hutchinson
taught that
uh if you dedicated your life as an
individual
as a mindful thoughtful responsible
individual to making
the world a better place for all those
around you
it wasn't about you it was about working
as hard as you could
for the betterment of others then he
prophesied that the collateral benefit
of behaving in that way would be your
own happiness
and in fact he said that the best if not
the only way to be happy
was to dedicate your life to everyone
else around you
and so so there's that idea of each one
of us he was saying each one of us as an
individual
but our best hope of happiness is to
dedicate all of our effort
to to everybody else and in
due course one of his students who was
john witherspoon emigrated to north
america and became the second president
of what is now
at princeton university and he became he
was one of the signatories of the
declaration of independence
and it's it's believed by many that the
very idea of
the pursuit of happiness that i've
already mentioned and that is enshrined
in the declaration of independence
is a product of francis hutchinson's
teaching
that happiness was something that would
be that you could pursue
actively with every shred of your being
as long as you dedicated it to the to
helping others so i think that
i think the dangerous split that you're
that you're describing there is when we
think that
not only are we individuals but we're
the most important
and the only thing that matters and that
our needs
and our identity is paramount and and
everybody else must also
sort of worship our individuality i
think that's a dangerous inversion and i
think
it's better to go with the francis line
which is yes you are an individual
your soul weighs the same as every other
soul from highest
to lowest but the the best and perhaps
the only
meaningful contribution you can make to
reality
into the future is to slog your guts out
absolutely and to do something for
others i mean
one of the i i can speak for myself you
know with us doing this show
i i've never been happier than doing it
now and that's because you're with me
mate
well that that you could say i'm happy
in spite of that but
um no but seriously though i mean you
know we get so many people who contact
us and say
that it's giving them reassurance as you
talked about or
it's giving them a sense that they're
not alone you know there's a feeling of
of us creating something that
that is for the benefit of other people
and that gives us i think tremendous
fulfillment
and that's probably the conflict that
where all three of us trying to hone in
on which is
where's that line between you being um
an individual who only cares about
themselves uh
which which is one extreme or being
someone who
who's who doesn't have any identity at
all it's just a cog in a machine which
would be
the kind of chinese model at the moment
for example and there's got to be
a point somewhere in between those where
we recognize the sanctity of every human
being
while also recognizing that it's not
possible for me to be happy and
fulfilled and
and wealthy and whatever else it might
be for any of those things to to be a
reality in my life
unless i'm creating something that is of
value to other people
yes i mean i couldn't i don't see how
any i don't see how any thinking
reasonable rational person could could
dispute
that as a premise um i think
we are being strangely i think there's a
there's a sad poignant irony in the fact
that
you know that the internet you know in
its you know it's earliest
you know iteration back in the 60s and
70s when it was being developed as
arpanet and it was this nodal
thing that was going to be proof against
you know you know nuclear war and
computers would keep on
talking to one another and that was the
the aspiration for it by the us military
who funded the research
but the kind of sandal long-haired that
you know hippie scientists in mit and
whatever that got behind it
they they had this utopian fantasy that
by bringing everyone together
via the internet that that free sharing
of information
uh would enable each individual to make
a contribution and we would all be
uh we would all be brought together by
the by the internet i think it's so
poignant that
in its present iteration it seems to be
atomizing us
in a strange way but almost being driven
apart
until eventually the only sort of
logical end game is for us all just to
be
uh you know isolated individuals
in our echo chambers you know shouting
like mad people
uh at the wider world um
and i'm not well i think i do have
luddite tendencies if i'm quite honest
i'm not proposing i'm not proposing that
we that we do away with
with all of this interconnectivity that
we have but
i think it has to be countered by
something else
i in the last few years i i began uh
doing um you know of a live show you
know i had written a book and i took it
as a as
a stage presentation theaters up and
down the country i did about 70
theaters and a terrifying uh
prospect it was you know you you know
being you know in your line of in your
other line of work you know standing on
a stage is a terrible lonely thing
but but once once i had done a few
performances
that that sense of connection to
real actual breathing human beings in
the same room as me
meant that if i felt it was the best
thing i do think it's the best thing
i've ever done
having reached out to people via
television having reached out to people
via books
and newspaper journalism and now it's
you know there's
podcasts and and various other ways of
reaching out but
that simple act of standing alone on a
stage
in a room with five or six hundred
people in it
and and hearing feeling their
expectation about what you were going to
say and then responding to that
getting their live feedback in real time
i think we
we need uh to be reminded of ourselves
as much as possible as
as made of meat and not made of the
silica
that's in our computers you know where
we respond
to one another physically in real spaces
in real time and i think the antidote to
a lot of the antagonism and
the aggression that's there at the
moment it's just by
people being brought physically together
it's like when you drive your car and
you feel free to shout and scream at
other people
inside their little glass boxes or their
glass and steel boxes
but if you were to wind down the window
and be confronted with the reality of
them you would behave all together
differently
because all of your instinctive human
responses would kick back in
effortlessly and we i think the way in
which we
we start to value one another properly
again
is by as much as possible being you know
in face to freeze content and it sounds
like such a you know a cliche
oversimplified thing to say but i think
we have to
make contact again with with what we are
as
as as animals you know i was i am i did
a bit of filming
a couple of years ago now in australia
um
and we were with an indigenous group in
arnhem land and they they took us out
crocodile hunting
at night uh and i've never hunted i had
never hunted anything done a bit of
fishing
and i was on a boat on a river in the
dark in arnhem land
and we were using torches to find you
know crocodiles their eyes light up like
amber in the darkness
and the boat slid without any power just
drifted on the current until it was
right alongside
a crocodile and and one of the hunters
put a heart through a harpoon
got it just behind its head and its
things these meters of thrashing angry
muscle were hauled aboard the boat
and then it was taken to a riverbank and
and it was it was a legal hunt you know
the indigenous people of arnold have
gone through the high courts and have
and have regained the right to hunt
the salt water crocodiles in that way
and then we stood around and watched as
this
as one of the hunters used a boning
knife you know to kill the crop
cut its head off and then it was cooped
and we all shared the meat of it and i
cannot tell you what a profound
experience it was to be beside something
quite large as it was as it was killed
and then butchered and then it became
the meat that we
ate and in our 21st century western
world
we couldn't be more removed from the
reality of that you know you buy these
shrink wrap
portions of unrecognizable meat and take
them home and cook them and
you're invited to think that they're
just some sort of you know magical
product that involves new life and death
and we've been because we've distanced
ourselves from the reality of
of the animals we've become less in awe
of life and death and if you're not in
awe of death and life then
you don't properly appreciate in fact
you don't appreciate at all
what it is to be alive i mean don't you
think neil as well that and and
i'm really glad because i wanted to ask
you this question and we're touching on
it now that
in the west death has become a taboo
subject
and we don't like to accept the fact no
not like we don't want to accept the
fight that life is finite and we are
going to die
well it's a strange thing yeah we've
done away because
you know during the long centuries of
religion where people one way or another
were being reassured of something other
than life
you know for the last couple of hundred
years people have increasingly accepted
or had to accept that this is all there
is and so for a lot of people naturally
the only
the only objective now is to stretch out
as long as possible
and to still have ripped abs and all
your own teeth when you're 90
because this is all there is and
and and because death is now is now
regarded as this full stop
void abyss of nothingness you know
people just
won't contemplate its existence
at all and now comes along something
like a pandemic
where everyone's been being made to
contemplate the possibility
of their unexpected death it's it's it's
unlikely given
given the nature of covert 19 but
nonetheless it's brought it back into
people's
minds perhaps in a you know in a real
way that we haven't thought about for a
while and i think we
this is what i mean this is what i'm
saying all the way through this i hope
this this idea that
you know for for 99
of the existence of any form of humanity
on planet earth for four million years
or longer
death was right there you know they were
they were
they were they had you know they were
experiencing injury and death
and responding to it and and
and yet they weren't they weren't living
in terror of it and they were respectful
in the face of them you know there's
you can there's a there's a there's a a
mesolithic
cemetery in vedback outside modern day
copenhagen and denmark and they
excavated the 1980s
there's many many uh
burials there and they're six or seven
thousand years old
and one of them famously is a mother and
baby a woman and a baby lying side by
side buried together presumed to have
died in childbirth
and both been buried and the woman has a
necklace of red deer teeth
with her and other items and the baby
was laid on a white swan's wing
either because the people thought that
by associating the spirit of the baby
with
migratory birds that leave and then
return that perhaps the spirit of the
baby would
would be gone for a while and then like
the birds would come back or it might be
no more than certainly a father or a
grandfather
wanting to put something comforting in
the ground rather than lay the baby down
on the cold clay
but in any event you look at you look at
that and what you see what the
archaeologists excavated along with
everything else
is are the human emotions of grief and
love without a shadow of a doubt you're
seeing grief and love
preserved in the ground after thousands
of years the most ephemeral of human
emotions there they are
as vivid as in those moments when they
were being experienced by other
living people and those mesolithic
hunters were living in circumstances
utterly unrecognizable to ours
where death was an ever-present threat
but every day had to be
a preoccupation with finding enough food
to feed yourself and your family
and dealing with threat and danger and
unknown and yet they still found it
within themselves the capacity to
express
love and emotion in a way that survived
in the ground for
thousands of years and is there like a
message in a bottle for us to discover
and to be struck by you know and
and these are people who who we would
think of as being primitive
and then even other species you know
there's neanderthal burials in shannada
in turkey not even our own species and
one of those one of the burials inside
that cave hadn't been back filled with
soil but with cut flowers
a neanderthal body had been laid down in
a grave and then covered over with fresh
flowers
and then another burial was of a man who
had lived into his forties which would
make him ancient by the standards of the
day
but he was missing one arm and he was he
had been blind because of an injury to
one eye
it would have been a burden you would
say to his tribe and yet they kept him
with them and looked after him and fed
him
until he died of old age so that we see
that people in
unimaginably difficult circumstances
confronted the reality of
of what it is to to live and to die and
and
and found these elegant expressions of
everything that they were feeling
and for us with all that we have in the
21st century
so important perhaps more important than
any other time i would say we should
look back
and acknowledge the wisdom of those
people
who had for whom death was a daily
possibility a daily reality and yet they
responded
to in such an upright and elegant
fashion that we should hang our heads in
shame
about the way in which we we hide away
from the realities of life and death
well speaking of learning the lessons of
the past as we wrap up
uh as what what should we consider
the primary lesson of the past that we
should be
attempting to learn because as we know
the you know the lesson of the past is
no one learns the lessons of the past
but but if we were to transcend that for
the first time in human history in a
significant way
what would we look to now to say this
is the inspiration we must take as a
society to overcome
the strife and the discord and the
division that we seem to be experiencing
in this current moment
i think that's a that's a hard that's a
hard question constance
i would see if we could find it with if
we could just
accept ourselves and each other for what
we are which is
blessedly flawed individuals
with you know each of us with the
capacity for great good and great
kindness
living side by side in the same body
with the capacity for
great cruelty and and and wrong doing
that for all that we have demonstrated
time and time again over thousands of
years
the ability to come together and share a
dream
and an idea and an aspiration and to
reach for it
and in some cases to come extremely
close to making it real
and and to and to actually realizing
hopes and dreams that
those feats have been accomplished by
flawed weak
human beings you know naked of fur
or feather without claws and big teeth
you know with frail internal organs
behind a basket of bones and
you know three pounds of rosy pink meat
under a cap of bone
such a fragile creation and yet we have
we have demonstrated again and again
in sometimes in possibly difficult
circumstances that that potential
for unlimited reach
even though man's reach must always
exceed his grasp you know we have that
within us and
if we could just respect that about each
and every one of us
then that's that's the foundation for
everything and what a wonderful note to
end
uh the interview on but the last
question that we always ask neil is
what's the one thing that we're not
talking about as a society
that we really should be um i think it's
maybe been woven through some of what
we've been talking about but i think
we've
completely lost touch lost any
meaningful concept of what it means to
be happy
and and the very idea i think we're
pursuing
faster and faster harder and harder with
every ounce of our being
happiness down a road where we won't
find it
and we need to have a major
corrective and a major rethink and to
look back into the past into the wisdom
of of the ancestors
and and re-learn rediscover what it even
means to be happy
and if we understand what it means to be
happy we might have half a chance of
getting there
that's a really good point neil that's a
really really interesting point
thank you so much for taking the time to
speak with us before we let you go
tell everybody where they can get your
books uh where they can follow you on
the evil social media that we've been
discussing
uh and uh where else they can check out
more of your work and more about you
uh on twitter i am there as the coast
guy
uh i have a book coming out in september
called the wisdom of the ancients which
deals with a lot of these ideas that
have been you know that we've been
chatting about
and my last book was called the story of
the british isles in 100 places and it's
a kind of a love letter
to the to this landscape i have a
podcast
called neil oliver's love letter to the
british isles
uh so there's there's various uh
formats and platforms out there through
which i'm trying to
communicate some ideas that i'm happy to
share and have challenged by
any reasonable listeners viewers but
honestly thanks so much you know the
opportunity to be on
uh on your the podcast and the chance to
have these long
free-flowing conversations to have
unexpected questions and just have to
answer them
uh on the hoof is a great experience so
thanks very much for having me
it's our absolute pleasure and you i
have no doubt that our viewers and
listeners have enjoyed it
uh as much as we have uh thank you very
much for tuning
make sure you get neil's books and his
latest when it comes out check out his
work follow him on twitter and we'll see
you in a couple of days with another
live stream
or another brilliant episode like this
one absolutely guys thank you so much
for tuning in and please remember
all our episodes and live streams go out
at 7 00 pm now that's 7 p.m
take care and see you soon that's 7 p.m
uk time you bigger
there's a whole world out there with
people no there's not mate there's just
england just south london can't believe
i said that in front of a scot oh well
i knew it wasn't going to come back on
it doesn't matter
all right guys take care we'll see you
soon
thanks for watching guys as always
subscribe to the youtube channel
click the bell button next to subscribe
button so you get notified when a video
comes out
and follow us on all the social media at
trigger pod
and also leave us a nice review on
itunes and spread the word